>>Student: Playing games in
school is helping me learn better
than I ever had before
in any other subject
in other schools I've
been to in my entire life.
>>Student: Do we have any more green?
>>Student: Where's the key?
>>Student: Wait, so how
about the top is right here?
I'll start like--
>>Student: Wait, are we
supposed to do it on this side
or do we do it on the back?
>>Teacher: The only
thing you're making
in this round is a good continent.
Possibly an isthmus, if you
earn it, islands and peninsulas.
So it will be very blank
except for your continent name.
>>To somebody who's never
seen Galactic Mappers before,
basically it looks like a class-wide
map making slash art project,
where students are working in
teams to build different sections
of a gigantic map of the world.
The better the students do, the more
complex their continent can get,
because they will keep earning.
And then the more they earn, the
more challenging the game becomes.
And if they want to have a
really fully developed continent,
that need to know within them
is going to start to seek
out this additional information.
>>Teacher: North,
>>Students: South,
>>Teacher: East,
>>Students: West.
>>Teacher: You have a land mass?
>>We have one, and then
we can make this into another one.
>>Well, that would
make you have two continents,
Is there another way--
>>Yes we have another--
we have different people around.
>>Teacher: Okay, group number one
and group number five
you guys have an isthmus.
You need to somehow share that
isthmus between the two of you,
you guys can communicate amongst
yourselves to make that isthmus work.
>>An embedded assessment is a form
of assessing students'
knowledge while they're engaged
in the learning process.
So rather than giving them a
test at the end of the unit,
we try to find ways of assessing
them while the learning is
actually happening.
>>Student: Rubric: your
group will be graded
on the following qualities,
map skills.
>>Student: It demonstrates
clear knowledge of the category
and physical geography
while playing the game.
Being positive in the
group, it's up ten points.
Yeah, be positive.
>>Student: Okay, so now what?
>>Teacher: So what I do in
advance is I create a rubric
with certain things
I'm going to look for.
Part of what I'm assessing them
does include content knowledge.
It includes application
of that content knowledge.
It also looks at systems
thinking and design thinking.
And I assess them just by either
listening to the types of things
that they're saying about
the different pieces.
So if I can hear a student explain
to another student why they want
to put certain things in a particular
spot or correcting students
on certain map technique
or something, you know,
those are good clues as to that
student's depth of knowledge.
>>Student: Sunny Bacon is
a continent where aliens
like Kay and Kodos eat a lot.
So that's why it's called Sunny
Bacon, it's based on breakfast.
>>Student: Sunny Bacon has a
lot of vegetation and hills
and a lot of mesas, yeah.
>>Teacher: Galactic Mappers forces
students to use their knowledge
of maps to apply it to something
that hasn't been created before.
So they're designing a map from
the ground up, and the maps some
of these groups design, they get this
done in twenty minutes, you know,
in a group of four or five.
So it allows them to really make sure
that they're properly designing a
good map with sensible map components
and also incorporating
physical geography
as well as cartography skills.
So Galactic Mappers tests that.
>>There is a peninsula
on this continent.
Can you show me where
the peninsula is?
Excellent job, and you
have one other card.
I see you have an isthmus card.
Where is your isthmus leading to?
Where's the isthmus?
Very good, excellent.
>>In the discussion phase of Galactic
Mappers, it really gets them to think
about maps in a collaborative
space and sort
of imagine the possibilities
of a spot on earth.
So it becomes more than just making
a map, it's also designing a living,
breathing planet, and it gets them to
start thinking about the components
of that planet in a different way,
and the possibilities if we were
to put people on this planet.